the [ __ ]  hey i'll stoop your [ __ ] eyes out  what's happening security too far away  to hear us  let's not do anything we're actually  here we just tune in south  we don't scroll honest to god xpd of a  preacher's little boy  murdered ring any bells  uh which preacher i just got a fresh  batch  with boys no clue who they're dead  bryce stone circuit writer on news 54  son was bobby stone 12 years old when he  died  are we talking black white chicano  any identifying marks style of execution  papa i think i know the one he wants  bd 9430  kindly handed the [ __ ] over now  all right please just relax just take it  freddy sir  it's just behind us on the shelf  bd 9430 that's  the one just  uh  you